this is an absolute Game Changer now
apart from this suit looking absolutely
incredible and badass this suit is
incredibly practical and will be hard to
be defeated while using it so as muff
Gideon explains an episode this is the
next Generation Dark Trooper suit which
has been made from beskar alloy which
means it's going to be incredibly
resistant against blasters pretty much
no blast will be able to penetrate this
armor so this guy will be a walking
machine of hell and will be very hard to
be taken down and this suit has a bloody
jet pack so if muffgidden somehow gets
into trouble he can just fly away now I
do want to get back to the looks of this
suit because the first time I saw this
suit I was just I was just taken back to
be honest it's like seeing a Ferrari for
the first time like what a damn
beautiful sight definitely a lot to be
taken in and I could just look at him
for ages and with more kid in his
performance his character is slowly
becoming one of my favorites just
because he's incredibly badass with his
new suit and he just steals every scene
that is in he just has this type of
Charisma where you just want to keep
listening to what he has to say and your
attention is fully diverted to him but
anyway that brings us to the conclusion
of this reader I really just wanted to
talk about how badass the suit is and
how efficient this suit really is but
anyway if you guys are new to the
Channel please consider subscribing and
leave a like if you enjoyed thanks for
watching guys